une fois de plus tous unis derrière une
seule volonté rendre hommage aux
victimes et dire non à la barbarie avec
pour unité le drapeau bleu blanc rouge
et je suis charlie un rassemblement
d'élus et de citoyens
je pense que le message est bien sûr et
très très très important c'est l'avenir
de notre pays quelque part qui se joue
depuis quelques heures
et dire écoutez c'est aussi un
représentant de la république de porter
ces messages ce que nous avons fait
d'une façon très très humble aujourd'hui
à rambouillet mais avec aussi beaucoup
de force
oui c'est de l'émotion mais de l'homme
est ce l'émotion combattante et avec
toute la force qui nous unis ont lavé
aujourd'hui haranguer nous entre en
résistance pour que nos libertés soient
sauvés je suis abdelkader j'en suis fier
mais ma république est fière aussi
d'avoir abdelkader à la tête d'une
circonscription telle que celle de
rambouillet chargé d'histoire changer de
toute l'histoire de la france c'est pas
une réaction en particulier à charlie
hebdo ça aurait pu être le canard ça
aurait pu être n'importe quel autre
journal c'est c'est la même chose on tue
la liberté d'expression charlie hebdo
était bien sûr réputé pour ses
caricatures les traits de crayon célèbre
de cabu charb et tant d'autres leur mort
a éveillé chez certains rambolitains d
envie de prendre le crayon
j'ai eu envie de chez pas javier jacquot
pas dans le photo club bouchut qui avait
fait 1 avait fait un croquis puis
géologie bagages
je me suis mis une bonne feuille de
papier puis j'ai laissé faire le crayon
c'est tout comme ça c'est clair
un moyen de rendre hommage c'est un bien
grand mot mais j'avoue j'ai eu envie de
faire je les fais dans cette marche
républicaine se côtoyaient toutes les
générations et même les citoyens de
demain
une occasion pour certains parents de
partager leurs valeurs
la semaine a été très difficile avant
tout pour nous et aussi pour eux c'était
un choc pour toute la famille on leur a
transmis
voilà qu'est ce qu'on a ressenti nous et
et on a été touchés droite au coeur
voilà on a pu leur transmettre ce que ce
en quoi on croit et ce en quoi on pense
dix mille personnes ont défilé à
rambouillet s'ajoutant ainsi aux près de
4 millions de français qui se sont
rassemblés un peu partout dans le pays
faisant de cette journée un événement
historique
bienvenue dans part nous voulions
commencer avec ces images d'une
manifestation il y en a eu des centaines
en france qui ont réuni des millions de
personnes tout le monde et est charlie
dimanche dernier est-ce que nous sommes
encore charlie une semaine plus tard
qu'est ce qu'il faut penser de ces
manifestations qu'est ce qui va rester
pour en parler
jean charles lajoie denis éditeurs
bonjour florence mercadé toujours
avocate toujours amical bonjour georges
leygues paddec toujours restaurateurs
sauvignon bonjour patrice mustapha
larbaoui toujours pharmaciens et
président du football club de trappes la
ville rose en avance patrice de
véronique turbide de verseilles plus
alors aux nouveaux venus
quand nous accueillons avec plaisir
photo d'un moule à vous êtes blogueur
est aussi le co fondateur du journal le
complément et voilà vous raconterai ce
que vous avez fait dimanche dernier
et puis et puis évidemment sephora me
dit toujours étudiante à l'université un
mot justement sur ces manifestations qui
est allé
manifestez personne c'est juste moi moi
je suis allé manifester à paris ballard
et c'était 1 c'était un beau mouvement
avec beaucoup de mixité en tout cas dans
la partie où je me trouvais il y avait
une très grande mixité ce n'était pas là
où je me trouvais dans cet endroit là ce
n'était pas que
des bons blanc bourgeois du coin café
année c'est une des choses qu'on a dites
sur ces manifestations qu'on n'a pas
forcément vu parce que c'est vrai que la
presse a résisté beaucoup sur base d une
banque et dans cette manifestation mais
beaucoup de gens qui étaient visés mais
ce n'est quand même assez blanc à ces
bourgeois assez bon beau parent proche
et qui est trop de blanc mais pas là non
ça c'est pareil comme réflexion
ce scénariste études parce qu'on va le
qsi
c'est la manifestation de toute la
france est ce que c'est vraiment toute
la france qui est manifestée on verra
après sur les réseaux sociaux
vraisemblablement il ya des gens qui
n'étaient pas d'accord avec tout ça mais
voilà c'est pour ça que je n'étais pas
d'accord était pas là en tout cas ceux
qui étaient là mais c'est bel et bien
voilà il y avait une ambiance très
effectivement très fraternel et surtout
parce que j'ai beaucoup aimé c'est une
passage avec les tireurs d'élite qui est
des deux tireurs d'élite qui était rodin
des immeubles avec je me suis dit faut
qu'ils en profitent et les tireurs
d'élite et les policiers parce que les
applaudir leur dire merci c'est
peut-être la première fois de leur vie
je ne sais pas si ça va être la dernière
mais en tout cas il y avait ce beau
mouvement et les tireurs d'élite en eau
était probablement un peu surpris et
c'est ont participé en faisant en disant
bonjour en ayant des gestes vers la vers
la foule aussi mais c'est charles voilà
ce qui fait le succès exactement c'est
pas sûr séraphin très plaisir
c'est clair le glas sonne enfin
retentissent à notre dame on à +10 la
police en souvenir de charlie hebdo il
n'ya pas construire cerné par une
prestation pour la liberté il on va au
delà de blé verdict pourquoi vous êtes
allé et pour une fois qu à versailles
événement personnes avaient manifesté
quoi abbas que par solidarité par cette
envie de dire que la liberté
d'expression c'est juste la base du pays
et que c'est hyper important et pour une
fois qu à versailles avait un allié de
poids sur voilà une manif qui me
plaisait à versailles j'y suis allé
alors oui alors moi je
je me suis on s'est rassemblé le jour
même en fait 17h30 au pied de téléphiles
avec une quinzaine de personnes et on a
organisé un petit rassemblement et puis
le jeudi on a organisé un événement à la
fac pour discuter de des événements et
en faveur bien sûr de la liberté
d'expression après je dissocierait un
peu le les émotions qu'ils ont sont
manifestés durant les premiers jours et
puis là la manifestation de dimanche qui
était aussi une manifestation d'émotion
mais sous une bannière j'ai pas
retrouver le mot d'ordre en faveur de la
liberté d'expression dans la presse j'ai
lu au moment où ça se faisait je lisais
marche contre le terrorisme pour moi
c'était alors je suis convaincu que les
personnes qui étaient est justement pas
pour le temps était était n'était pas à
mon avis venus manifester contre le
terrorisme et j'espère pour la liberté
d'expression parce que c'est que ça mon
avis c'est une façon plus positive de
réclamer une société pacifique
néanmoins je suis un peu déçu quand même
de la récupération qui a été fait
opération comme en bas sous le sous le
thème de l'union nationale en fait je
pense que la liberté d'expression c'est
un principe universel et que donc c'est
une valeur qui peut être revendiquée par
par tout le monde
je pense que ça aurait été bien de
garder cette thématique là durant cette
manifestation du dimanche sans forcément
avoir des chefs d'état internationaux
juste devant voilà pourquoi parce que
parmi les chefs d'état il n'est pas que
des démocrates d'ailleurs donc vous
n'avez pas pour manifester contre le
terrorisme en fait si j'ai bien compris
en fait pour moi une manifestation c'est
ça plutôt positifs comme négatifs la
valeur but de faire progresser des idées
et quand on manifeste des émotions ça
peut être sympathique mais s'il n'y a
pas derrière des revendications
politiques
c'est un peu inutile surtout quand il ya
des personnes des personnages politiques
qui font au contraire de ce qu'il
faudrait faire pour préserver de la
liberté d'expression dans leur pays et
que la manifestation n'est pas
clairement identifiés comme
demandant un progrès pourquoi n'a pas
discuté aujourd'hui des limites des
limites de la liberté d'insulter tout à
l'heure les slogans étaient pas qu'on
n'était pas contre le terrorisme tous
les slogans entendus c'était ensemble
uni pour la démocratie et pour la
liberté
la cour des comptes était rythmé les
slogans qui s'est uni ensemble pour la
démocratie et liberté liberté qui était
répétée toulouse je suis certain que
tous les manifestants étaient sincères
dans leurs convictions après la
présentation médiatique des médias
dominants c'est autre chose on va
résonner l'union nationale
si on veut faire descendre quatre
millions de gens heureusement qu'on
simplifie un peu le propos et qu'on
essaie de trouver des trucs un petit peu
cancer sudron et consensuelle parce que
sinon c'est la fin sinon on se retrouve
à 15 comme quand vous étiez devant tv
fille du roi jeudi à savoir si on veut
être 15 sur 24 millions ça me fasse il a
lancé un beau bizarre 3 à 50 ans on est
comme le faire un nom mais jean libanais
par nature je suis pas à suivre
je n'ai jamais été je ne serai jamais
donc je n'avais pas l'intention d'aller
manifester
j'ai pas acheté charlie hebdo j'ai
regardé comme tout le monde ce qui ont
été montrées il ya de la provocation
c'est bien faut être libre de pouvoir
provoquer dans la presse j'ai dit à la
précédente émission que si nous avions
été plus courageux et si nous avions les
caractères loi mais à l'époque où le
fait que j'en fasse tenons douzamy
serait pas mort
donc si la manifestion de dimanche
permet à à nous tous d'être plus
courageux demain tant mieux nous aurons
gagné quelque chose je suis pas certain
que ce soit le cas donc je ne suis pas
un suiveur j'essaie d'avoir la réflexion
qu'il faut pour moi pour nous on va
parler nous et donc la liberté
d'expression évidemment qu'il faut se
battre pour la garder mais en même temps
ce qui se passe là ne me rend pas très à
l'aise mais ce consensus comme ça tout
d'un coup c'est faudra alors pour ma
part je ne suis pas allé manifester
j'avais 18 ans
pas que pas qu ils savaient des examens
j'étais malade mais comme dit jean luc
il ya ce côté un peu qui me dérange
rhinocérite par une série de l'unesco ce
mouvement de vague on se retrouve avec
mille et une personnes rassemblées et
quelque part chacun est là pour des
motifs qui lui sont propres
je suis charlie sémantiquement il ya
trois mois que veut dire je suis charlie
je suis pour la liberté d'expression
je suis contre les tories je suis pour
charlie hebdo ça veut tout et rien dire
donc je trouve que c'était un mouvement
historique pour une fois que les gens
sortaient un publicitaire qui a trouvé
ce slogan il faudra qu'il a déposées
voilà qui n'a pas perdu de vue la
possibilité de faire de l'argent et
justement c'est ça c'est bon on est tous
sortis de notre individualisme
on s'est rassemblé sa marque un temps
historique
en cela c'est bien tous les gens qui
sont venus soutenir la liberté
d'expression je pense que c'était
important de le faire c'était aussi un
moyen de dire nous n'avons pas peur vu
qu'il y avait une forme de psychose dans
paris j'étais à paris deux jours avant
il y avait des gens dans la rue en cela
c'était important
maintenant je me méfie un peu de ce
mouvement de masse juste un tacle à vous
est le même le même analyse que
jean-louis mustapha vous étiez en
algérie et je trouve ça intéressant
parce que qu'elle était la réaction de
dsk une réaction de bord et quelle a été
la réaction des gens que vous avez
rencontrés alors d'abord je tiens à
préciser que je suis en âge et non pas
pour manifester à alger j'y suis allé
parce que c'était prévu feyenoord
imprimé mais bon c'était pas le jour
celle ci s'était pas c'était pas à la
fois
un mouvement de manifestation mais c'est
simplement parce que je crois qu'il ya
eu on a parlé de 6 millions de gens qui
ont manifesté ce qui prouve qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui n'ont pas manifesté
probablement même beaucoup plus sauf que
bien évidemment la vie continue des
activités des uns et des autres
continuant moi j'étais prévu d'être en
algérie effectivement mais aura 900 à
peu près 50 4 millions de gens qui n'ont
pas 21st vous faut au moins de rappeler
et montrer aussi que ceux qui n'ont pas
manifesté ne sont pas ceux qui n'ont pas
souhaité mais il y avait beaucoup de
talent voilà moi j'étais en algérie et
je peux vous dire que comme dirait
nougaro des lions pas j'ai senti le choc
parce que dès l'aéroport j'ai été
accueilli par les gens de la famille
ligne et c'est la première chose qu'ils
m'ont dit après quelques embrassades
c'est de dire voilà c'est terrifiant ce
qui vous arrive et en même temps on sait
de quoi on parle on parle de l'algérie
dans les années 90 les années absolument
terrifiante où le terrorisme a frappé
très très fort durablement et
durablement de cours sur ce peuple mais
clairement sachant de quoi il parle en
parle de terrorisme cette fois ci qui
était violent à cette époque c'est
vraiment un 3gs qui oublient ce que les
algériens ont bien connu c'est vraiment
la première chose qui a été dit
voilà donc à ce vrai mouvement de
solidarité que moi j'ai senti aussi au
delà des frontières au-delà de la
méditerranée
maintenant sur le fond puisqu'on a
ouvert sur le fond alors je me repose et
de la culture à plein différemment on a
dit qu'il y aurait peut-être un avant et
un après 7 janvier c'est à dire avant et
après l'attentât charlie hebdo et puis
là on parle on en avant et après 11
janvier c'est-à-dire un avant et un
après manifestation est ce que vous
pensez que voilà une autre france qui va
se construire après cette manifestation
où on est encore ceux ci ont été ça sur
notre collaboration est le moi je compte
sur un je considère que on pourra ouvrir
le débat sur l'idée qu' effectivement
c'était finalement pas une manifestation
d'habitués en france des manifestations
mais face à son agresseur rassemblement
les pharmaciens deux avocats c'est plus
une communion fraternelle senti que les
gens avaient envie de se retrouver qu'il
y avait besoin
voilà donc cette communion là tout le
monde avait besoin jeudi
tout le monde m'a simplement parce que
manager éric brassard et donc moi ça ce
que j'ai c'est ce que j'ai retrouvé je
pense qu'on est à mon avis pas pas au
niveau du débat si on commence à
regarder à la loupe
quelle couleur était représentée qui a
dénombré très représentés mais je pense
qu'il faut garder l'unité à la fois de
cette foule à lattes faute cette émotion
mais il ya un avant et un après il ya
des moments où tout simplement il ya des
moments certes sepa sepa sepa stratégie
qui a pas une stratégie de mobilisation
ce jour là pour dire on va aller
défendre unités de il ya il ya eu
d'abord une émotion et effectivement on
peut y souscrire ou pas on peut
techniquement ou pas mais d'abord je
pense qu'il ya des moments dans la vie
comme dans une famille on va tous au
cimetière on se rassemble et puis après
après l'enterrement il ya déjà des
langues qui se délient il était pas s'il
n'était pas si cool que ça va et ça m'a
fait un peu ses tables cette impression
donc dans tout fait quand il ya un drame
dans une famille sait jamais tout à fait
pareil je pense qu'il y aura un avant et
un après de qui alors j'en sais rien
mais un havre à un importateur je suis
assez d'accord c'est vrai qu'il ya une
ressemblement un besoin de se rassembler
et puis aussi à des gens qui avaient une
stratégie qui ont profité aussi pour
récupérer cette ses émotions et se laver
en fait un peu comme les anti g20 les
chefs d'état des chefs d'état est ce que
vous avez été choqué par exemple qu'est
le le président turc eux aura des gens
qui voient là qu'il est dès le lendemain
dès le lendemain condamne la parution de
ces reliques coup après avoir manifesté
pour la liberté d'expression
quand même oui mais bien évidemment la
présence de ce sinistre personnage qui
nous vient de la turquie c'est une
insulte permanente à tout ce qu'on peut
aimer tout ce qu'on peut apprécier d'un
de dans la vie pour peu qu'on soit à peu
près normal donc ça se fait petit jour
c'est choquant maintenant dans un
rassemblement de deux d'une multiplicité
de chef d'état c'est pas très grave je
veux dire c'est une unité internationale
c'est pas grave après on va pas non plus
que commencer à donner des certificats
avec vous avez le droit d'être charlie
faisait pas loin d'être guéri
vous avez adressé aux dires de tous les
problèmes liberté d'expression est
protesté dès la parution d'une taille
dans la main quand même pardon je peux
quand même manifester une approbation
désapprobation de ce qui se passe dans
un pays sans toutefois avoir le même
sentiment chez lui je veux dire très
honnêtement la france n'a rien à voir
avec la turquie la turquie n'a rien à
voir avec la france
donc qu'il est un autre son de cloche
d'une façon de gérer les choses en
turquie
c'est le problème de la turquie quand on
est ça et ce n'est pas le mien prenant
l'espagnol à lui en espagne pour moi ça
reste une blague mais je les rejoigne
je sais bien où vous allez interdit les
rassemblements muller scène dans les
états bg je dirais m'habille libertés
fondamentales la bbc dans les problèmes
de l'espagne à l'espagne reste une
démocratie extraordinaire donc je ne
crie extra musica sacra cercle droit
s'est rassemblée dans la chimie est
composé de théories caractère bâti et
c'est des gens qui ont lutté pour les
ehpad y avait deux catégories de chef
d'état cette manifestation il y avait
ceux qui exprimaient leur position la
barbarie et ceux qui voulaient exprimer
le fait qu'ils étaient civilisé donc pas
barbare donc également très bien avec
lui et ont finalement au demeurant ces
deux catégories d'associés rassembler
avec le même intérêt c'est de montrer à
l'eau
néo-international que les uns étaient
contre la barbarie et que les autres
étaient civilisé donc pas barbare
finalement l'objectif devant l'ensemble
de l'opinion mondiale pour les deux
catégories de chefs d'état étaient très
intéressés seraient par hbo d'abbas
manifestons contre le terrorisme je suis
à 5 l'elysée ou d'abbas je suis contre
la barbarie disaient les autres c'est
vrai là dessus sur le chef detat ça vous
a choqué pas choquer je suis trouvée
c'est incohérent mais tellement
politique très politique
évidemment alors je reviens à cette
question est ce qu'il y aura un avant et
un après manif certainement parce que
incontestablement autant de monde dans
la rue avec 7 unités la marque un
tournant de l'histoire et le fait que
l'historique à votre grosso modo 25 %
des chefs d'état de la planète est
étaient présents à cette manifestation
c'est un signe fort alors pour la
barbarie je suis civilisé tout ça fait
quand même quand la fille âgée de 13 ans
mais nous a écoutés c'est non
alors après on va quand même pas faire
de la pub pour françois hollande sur le
sujet car n'importe quel chef d'état
aurait fait la même chose pendant
certaines heures ou demain 10 ans et ça
et c'était une opportunité incroyable
dans l'histoire devant le monde entier
que de marquer un tournant
ce tournant j'espère que nous allons
bien utiliser la rave quelques heures
qui viennent de passer entre dimanche et
maintenant démontre que on a plutôt
l'exacerbation d'un certain nombre ce
sentiment j'espère que ça va se calmer
étant entendu que finalement le
sentiment les sentiments contre la
civilisation et j'espère bien que
finalement la planète va comprendre que
nous sommes entrés dans une phase où
nous devons tous aller vers des
civilisations éclairé et contre la
barbarie n'est pas tout à fait on y
vient on y viendra
non mais je pense aussi à florence juste
devant je pense aussi que le message
passé par par cette foule importante
dans les
en france donne un signal aussi à nos
politiques puis à fort qui monte un peu
comme si en garde lancée contre les
auteurs me demande aussi à ce qu'il soit
à la hauteur et qui vont
fondamentalement c'est comme dans une
famille quand il ya un drame le peuple
français vient de subir un drame mais en
réalité c'est vraiment à l'international
pour regarder les choses j'ai parlé de
la jei volontairement dire que c'est un
témoignage pour un peuple mais c'est
également ce témoignage là qu'on pourra
apporter dans d'autres pays est en fait
à l'international quand on regarde bien
c'est à l'échelle mondiale que les gens
sont frappés dans les pays et moi il me
vieux quand je dis ça sera jamais pareil
parce qu on ouvre une page différente
voire même une discussion différentes la
première chose à laquelle j'ai pensé
c'est que on est on est persuadé en
france que la loi de 1905 régit le monde
et que la laïcité est une est un
principe de d'organisation de la cité or
je crois savoir qu il ya un pays sur
deux en europe dans le monde c'est pas
tout à fait le cas et j'ai comme le
sentiment que j'ai l'impression de vivre
les moments certains moments là pays
serait tout dire il n'est pas calé par
âge et par la laïcité
pardon il ya deux pays qui sont là et
qui en fait voilà c'est à dire c'est
pour dire ces mots sonnent chez le
cédrat la règle générale chaque
sédiments d'être voilà la planète
aujourd'hui devenu beaucoup plus
rétrécies qu'elle n'a été à une époque
on a eu ce débat en france qui aboutit
sur la 1905 et dieu sait si j'ai eu
d'ailleurs des manifestations des
attentats probablement les actes
qualifiés différemment l'époque mes
voyages
la réflexion que j'ai c'est qu'on a
ouvert un débat je crois sur la laïcité
au plan mondial c'est à dire que à la
fois dans les pays
le monde arabe des manières c'est le
crapa raciste la nation d'électricité et
ailleurs la notion de laïcité sur
lesquelles on va pouvoir parler c'est
parce que on va restreint ou par la
liberté d'expression la liberté
d'expression matin se restreindre à un
niveau où on parlera ou pas du fait
religieux etc
moi c'est ça je crois aux intéressés
sera le elles sont toutes beaucoup
d'affaires réalisé dans l'éclairage
diverses mondial c'est l'éclairage de la
société sur ses grands phénomènes qui
par rapport au religieux mais par
rapport aux phénomènes sociétaux en
général font qu'il va falloir que nous
choisissions entre un axe vers une
société civilisée et éclairé ou un axe
qui va plus de la religion et nous
savons tous que la moue risquons nos
rangs a choisi attentisme
nous nous avons choisi par la loi mais
en même temps n'oubliez pas une chose va
vous connaissez tous la grande phrase de
karl marx qui disait la religion c'est
l'opium du peuple
ça veut dire beaucoup de choses on sait
aussi que nous nous sommes sortis nous
de l'obscurantisme religieux
après des siècles de bagarres sanglantes
et j'espère que le mouvement de du 7
janvier va permettre d'aller vers une
société plus écrire les yeux je crois
hélas on revenir à votre question et je
suis assez d'accord avec mustapha ça ne
va déboucher sur rien parce que tout le
monde s'est donné une magnifique bonne
conscience avec ce défilé est très vite
là on voit un jeune je ne sais quelle
grande ville on a interdit avait annulé
la projection du film qui me doublent
tous parce que c'était plus le moment de
passer ce film là que sa lettre au sens
profond sa toile sur le massif deux fois
la dre leclerc c'est fini ça ça ouvre
vers quelque chose de quelque chose
d'autre
ça ouvre le jour même de l'attentât
bruxelles le pardon le gouvernement a
envoyé une notification à bruxelles pour
permettre de bloquer des sites
terroristes
alors j'aimerais
parler de liberté d'expression la
censure de l'internet en france et en
suisse
donc ça n'a strictement rien à voir mais
déjà de supprimer la projection de ce
film sous des sous des prétextes de peur
et de conflits à venir est hypothétique
c'est a toujours été absolument
monstrueux et ça ne va pas arrêter le
tout le monde commença à rétropédaler en
disant oui mais charlie hebdo
effectivement il allait peut-être un peu
loin est ce que tu es tu es intelligent
et c'est donc ça c'est définitivement
battu en brèche on s'est rassuré j'ai
enquêté je suis seul et il y en avait 21
ans environ 99% qu'il n'avait jamais lu
qu'il aimerait juste un an
quand je dis que ça va probablement
probablement ouvrir le champ de la
discussion sur la laïcité son plan
mondial c'est à dire qu'effectivement
moi je considère que toutes les
religions vont pouvoir cohabiter avec
des systèmes laïque je parle du futur
terre qu'il y aura une laïcité dans
différents pays et qui aura probablement
ce dialogue
c'est en ça que je dis faut faire aussi
attention parce que la république allait
française la laïcité est française mais
elle rayonne dans le monde et c'est vers
ça à mon avis que le débat va s'ouvrir
et probablement qu'on ira vers ça mais
justement ça ne veut pas dire pour
autant qu'on est dans une guerre de
civilisation
parce que toutes les civilisations
peuvent être tout laïque républicaine
simplement il ya des us et coutumes de
pays en pays des civilisations
probablement un peu différente en asie
en afrique et donc il ya des barbares
individuel il ya des gens qui rentrent
dans des schémas de terroristes de
terreur de fiona il ya des étapes mais
qui sont tenus par des individus
et qui font que leur pop est un service
13 ans mais maintenant mais on peut pas
dire qu'ils n'ont pas la démocratie et
qu'ils ont voté pour ses pas pour
revenir à ce que je parle de stylisation
de guerre de ses réalisations ya quand
même à mon avis une planète
mais de grâce à ça aussi c'est bien pour
revenir à la question de patrice je
pense que le dimanche dernier n'aura
aucune incidence sur la france ce qui se
passe en france mais peut heureusement
et de façon optimiste en avoir sur le
reste du monde parce que ça a été
pendant une journée le reste du monde et
des pays beaucoup moins libre que le
nôtre
beaucoup moins démocratiques etc ont vu
ces images et se sont dit tiens oui ils
réagissent il ya quand même quelque
chose marche assez là et ça c'est un
signe très fort je pense que dans le
monde entier c'est un message très fort
donc cette manifestation c'est ce
rassemblement démentiel peut sûrement
avoir une incidence tout à fait positif
sur le reste du monde en france n'est
probablement pas en tout cas la
manifestation à mon sens permet d'avoir
un éclairage sur un choix entre deux
options société simplement sur le
débouché moi je trouve que le débouché
actuel est d'une très mauvaise passe le
jour même des attentats une notification
est envoyé à bruxelles pour autoriser
les blocages de sites alors soi disant
terroristes ou pornographique et
pédopornographique
mais quel contrôle là dessus et là on
parle de liberté d'expression on sort
tous dans la rue on est 3 millions soit
disant sa discussion avec des
fournisseurs et ouattara parce que c'est
une liste ou non mais on met des sites
dedans et servait des conversations me
rappeler les attend il parle de censure
quand même là
vous avez des lois très spécifique avec
des délits des délits sur d2d line pour
entraîner dans l association georis des
lilas ils sont particulièrement
caractérisé problème est bien verte et
d'imposer à l'hébergeur de respecter la
loi et mais là c'est différent c'est à
dire que c'est une autorité
administrative qui fait une liste qui
ajoute des sites et auxquelles on peut
accéder
donc c'est le schéma qui s'exprimait
rejet mais attendez c'est pas qu'il
n'existe plus et si tu sais qu'il existe
plus pour nous ça veut dire qu'il ya une
censure partielle de l'internet avec
avec ce type 2 avec ce type de données
sur internet on a vu se multiplier
un certain temps puisque cette
manifestation avec des millions de gens
je suis charrie je suis charlie et puis
sur internet un peu de grain à moindre
degré évidemment mais afin dé message
totalement contraire de gens qui disent
ne pas du tout charlie on est plutôt du
côté des terroristes
donc il ya aussi derrière derrière cette
unité de façade comme ça il
elle craque elle un peu si on regarde ce
qui se passe un peu sur internet non
internet est extrêmement important je
veux dire que internet probablement déjà
aujourd'hui à supplanter la télévision
donc oui internet est très regardée et a
une influence de plus en plus par là
qu'il ya des messages qui étaient murées
oui contre les critiques et qui vont à
l'envers de l'ambiance générale très
étonnant qu'ils sont d'autant plus qu'on
a vu que c'est d'abord ça véhicule
effectivement c'est tout tous ces
messages de haine qu'on est absolument
répugnant qui sont répandus sur la toile
très rapidement ils sont maintenant
relayé 20 parolier parce qu'ils ne se
substituent pas ils s'ajoutent à ces
trucs encore plus fumeux ridicule de
théorie du complot ou là en allant
parler mais à longueur de journée sur
les réseaux sociaux cette théorie du
complot grotesque enfin suite insisté ça
la liberté sur internet et skype et
rhône ont d'argent
grotesque pourquoi est ce que tout le
monde aurait l'obligation d'avaler tout
ce qu'il nous est dit sur les
télévisions et les radios officielles
excuse moi chacun a quand même le droit
d'avoir une opinion
moi je gagne bien une chose qui me qui
aujourd'hui me gêne un peu c'est comment
at on pu retrouver une carte d'identité
d'un des deux frères dans la voiture bon
on a le droit de s'interroger on n'est
pas obligé de penser qu obligatoirement
le mec l'a perdue parce que la carte
d'identité dépenses est de dépasser de
la poche de son pantalon
alors là bas au fond de sa pensée tu
penses quoi alors je pense rien je
dispose at-il je sais que certains
droits de vue et j'avais envie d'aller
d'un autre côté on dit oui bon la
liberté c'est bien mais faut pas dire
n'importe quoi c'est un peu ça que vous
dites non un exemple concret prenons un
exemple concret celui de dieudonné
dieudonné qui dit je suis charlie
coulibaly alors est ce que c'est une
incitation au terrorisme
est ce que c'est de la liberté
d'expression voire moins pour moi je
n'en sais rien en tout cas ce que je
disais dérangeait pas non mais moi ce
que je souhaite pour vous c'est quoi
c'est de la liberté le problème c'est le
problème c'est que du coup on colle un
procès dont colin non mais on colle un
procès adieu à dieudonné
et du coup c'est plus fine que mon
stress à la question même la question
mais c'est la question c'est est ce que
pour vous et c'est de la citation dutau
terrorisme ou est ce que c'est de la
liberté d'expression c'est ça ma
question
mais c'est en tout cas le circuit qu'ils
en profitent qu'il en profite par nos
veines nous est si la question a exprimé
une intention
oui je sais peut-être un je sais pas si
c'est un appel au terrorisme j'en sais
rien honnêtement j'en sais rien en tout
cas il a exprimé c'est très ambigu et
puis et puis c'est la force a été fait
pour sa fille mais c'est justement
excusez moi je suis pas terminée ce
qu'on ne faisait pas que c'est pas
neutre parce que koulibaly est celui qui
accueille oui mais justement et joue
avec ça en sachant qu'il a un procès en
sachant que peut-être il va s'en sortir
parce qu' il s' est très floue et que du
coup notre système enfin notre liberté
d'expression limité elle permet de faire
de la pub à des expressions qui sont
tout à fait banale en privé
malheureusement été parlée d'expression
et la possibilité d'habiter c'est tout
aussi bon bah droit des propos
xénophobes des propos de haine
si on peut pas les affronter
frontalement actuellement dans le débat
public on ne peut pas compter que oui
bah non c'est toi le maire sait pas que
lsd foutra pas d'avis il utilisera un
double langage
mais non mais là vous votre langage vous
l'avez vous dire ce que vous voulez la
dire moi je suis d'accord avec toi
pourquoi vous dit pas je suis d'accord
ou pas d'accord du paradis non madame
vous avez la liberté
si vous voulez c'est typique mais parce
que les besoins courants car les avis
concernant ce n'est pas correct et c'est
bien ça guy l'accord est allé battre
rafa je pense bien pour savoir qui avait
dit après un peu près les poncifs de
temps en temps désolé c'est en est un il
ya des choses qu'on peut dire quand même
même si c'est des voix là je suis pas
forcément d'accord avec toi je me
battrai pourtant le temps qu'il faudra
pour que tu puisses ledit voile et
finalement on est dans un esprit charlie
s'il veut dire ce qu'il veut il dit ce
qu'il veut charlie elles sont liées à ce
jour dix mois finalement c'est par les
triades je parle d'antenne à donner ce
de ceux de ceux qui veulent s'exprimer
comme ils le souhaitent
maintenant ça sera tranchée par la
justice parce que la liberté
d'expression en france ça n'existe par
contre quelque chose il ya des propos de
son lit qui sont tenus par par des
règles et par des lois et ça sera ça
s'appelle un délit - très sincèrement
qu'il est dit je suis charlie slash
coulibaly moi j'ai entendu provost et
j'ai senti le m
provocation effectivement sauf que c'est
de la provocation qui est quand même
extrêmement allez allez on va le dire
annie est légèrement parce qu'on sait à
quoi s'est associée donc si on associe
le lien tissé métisse il associera
l'antisémitisme si on associe le mot au
terrorisme si on associe le mot c'est
évident je crois qu'on a mais n'y a pas
de sujet et je crois que ceux d'ailleurs
qui promeut la liberté d'expression 10
effectivement si demain on qualifie le
nom de colis ben ali devient antisémite
coulibaly devient terrorisme bien sûr
ces d'incitation à la haine et au
terrorisme
en revanche il ya plein de coulibaly en
france qui porte ce nom probablement que
ces gens là pourront dire voilà on en
attend dé moi je suis charlie coulibaly
sert je suis coulibaly de nom de famille
je me sens charlie et ses larmes
sermonnés où dieudonné un moment donné
il est tout le temps en train de se en
train de jouer comme lui et d'autres
faut arrêter un moment donné je jouais
sur les lignes comme ça c'est ça qui me
choque c'est probablement qu'il a droit
de le dire les problèmes ne s'était pas
un nom une incitation sais pas
probablement et ce sera bien chez jean
chirotech on me répond ah ben ça mais
patrice par contre oui au moment de les
je crois qu'il faut qu'on vit
dans une société où un moment donné il
faut qu'on arrête de jouer de résister
pas ça aussi la manifestation de dire on
ne veut plus non plus de sa trop de gens
qui jouent pas et qui joue justement sur
les sur les limites comme ça c'est fort
c'est vraiment son fond de commerce
c'est à dire que bon des blagues sur la
choix des mots l'action les juifs là
maintenant on prend charles coulibaly
c'est ça le problème c'est non c'est une
assistance permanente et qui à force
cela relève de l'antisémitisme alors il
reste toujours de façon ambiguë comme ça
flottant entre les deux c'est cette
forme d'assistance qui doit être
condamné en gros je me ferais pas super
parce que je pense que je vais trouver
un bon avocat
non c'est ce que tu veux dire quand le
pen d'autres où il ajouté je sais que
martyr
voilà soit je passe pour un martyr ou
alors je trouverai des failles de droit
qui fait qu'on va trouver une solution
ok on a compris tu as droit de le dire
donc probablement pas d'ailleurs mais en
même temps arrêtez arrêtez je suis
d'accord sur le sait c'est son fond de
commerce à dieudonné est justement le
fait
je peux répondre à cette question mais
je veux dire le fait qu'on passe notre
temps à s'indigner là dessus en fait ça
lui fait de la pub et c'est exactement
ce qui veut donc à mon avis le meilleur
façon de combattre c'est de le combattre
en parlant en parlant de liberté des
moeurs qui avait eu l'air de regretter
qu'on ressent sur un certain nombre de
messages appelant au terrorisme non
j'accepte pour satyam est alors alors à
leur jeu alors vous avez compris parce
qu'on a eu l'attention jeudi que je
regrette que le débat ne se sentent pas
sur les questions de liberté
d'expression et qu'on en revienne à des
personnalités assez sur le coeur et
qu'elle voulait je peux répondre à la
question c'est y répondre
alors répondez opposé à dieudonné tout
mouvement idéologique il ya derrière lui
c'est un co fondateur d'un parti avec un
néo nazi qui s'appelle alain soral je
suis foncièrement opposés à cet individu
je veux absolument pas je veux
absolument pas les citer mais c'est déjà
trop parlé pas que c'est le sécher c'est
lui le débat que tu veux mais ce que moi
je trouve que par contre le débat comme
ça le pharmacien on pourrait
probablement le pharmacien mais le
pharmacien
le pharmacien du couvent pour le coucher
la thérapeutique qui m'intéressent était
là prêt et les médicaments et de soins
qu'on peut apporter
moi je voudrais qu'on parle à mon avis
et surtout de ce qu'est la france forte
qu'elle soit debout probablement été mis
à terre
on a un peu tremblé mais y ait une
france forte
il ya une république forte il ya des
moyens il ya une expression libre en
france il ya des moyens militaires
policiers et sa relève je remercie mes
mollets cette france a existé je
voudrais qu'on en pense que celle ci
justement on était dans une forme très
pessimiste vous savez qu'on ait un le
moral plus bas que les afghans et état
est-ce que depuis dimanche
c'est pas un peu relevé comparer couvent
plus d'antidépresseurs de oui et non
c'est pour ça
pour ça qu'il est content non non non je
ne suis pas dans tous les cas la
profession ne l'est pas mais on est là
si nécessaire mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que oui on est là aussi comme il
faut vivre de livres de médicaments et
de médecine mais c'est vrai que moi
c'est ça qui me gêne c'est que quand
encore une fois je vais apporter ce
témoignage tout à l'heure de l'algérie
volontairement
j'ai connu un pays déprimé j'ai trouvé
un pays
quelques années après voilà qui rayonne
qui a bâti qui croit en son avenir et
qui pour autant déprimés qu'ils
l'étaient
la france amie probablement je ne sais
pas c'est peut-être un peu fort mais un
genou à terre probablement mais on se
relève de ça on doit se relever de ça il
ya des lois dans ce pays on peut les
appliquer on doit les appliquer et ici
en tant de septembre a parlé de quoi
prendre un poids pour les premières
émissions
on a parlé du du corps intermédiaires
qui devaient se mobiliser on a parlé
d'économie on a parlé du chômage c'est
parle plus de rien on a parlé des
locations de nabila s'il parlait de
nabila alors j'ai eu d'impact faut
revenir à parler de nabila forcément
maintenant probablement plus tard mais
au moins qu'on revienne à dire voilà
c'est dramatique et ce moment d'émotion
fort il ya un débat qui s'ouvre sur les
sur certaines méthodes mais je voudrais
pas qu'on perde de vue que pour le débat
cia il ya une planète qui à mon avis va
se tourner vers des débats qui en valent
la peine je parle de laïcité mondiale ou
la france et sa république qui pour moi
me tiens je vais à sa part une seconde
d'éducation il ya eu il est quand même
pas mal d'incidents dans les lycées
notamment quand les professeurs voulu
soit faire respecter une minute de
silence pour expliquer ce qui s'était
passé et beaucoup beaucoup d'élèves
redoublent non c'est bien fait pour eux
en parlant d' aider des gens de charlie
ils l'ont bien cherché
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous en
pensez de sart est ce que là c'est bien
eux qui disent qu'on puisse justement
lundi à manon oui non at-on cloche chez
eux il leur donnait un autre son de
cloche
ils reconnaissent qu'ils ont trouvé chez
play on imagine et donc que qu'on puisse
leur dire qu'ils aient à mettons un
professeur d'éducation civique ou de
laïcité ou je sais pas quoi qu'il puisse
leur dire maintenant
ce discours là il est propre à la
famille méthon mais nous on pense ça et
on peut penser autrement et c'est bien
que les choses soient dites bonne ou
mauvaise passe qu'il faut en avoir
conscience et arrêter de se voiler la
face
tout ça est très importante la soirée
s'est passée cette année une guerre
terrible parce que je suis pas persuadé
tu as tout à fait raison mais je peux
persuadé que les profs et pu mener le
débat jusqu'au bout dans certaines
classes hier que non mais le truc s'est
arrêté net il ya notamment même un prof
qui la proscrit
bon je veux dire de façon sûrement un
petit peu expéditif il est employé un
moyen qui était qui étaient là ils
avaient les caricatures de mahomet
attendons de attendons de voir un peu
lente
c'est peut-être un peu l'expéditeur
vraiment besoin d' écoute parce que ce
sont des gamins qui ont fait voir dix
ans 12 ans qu'attendre ils répètent
qu'ils entendent des grands frères ou
des oncles ou des parents etc
ces gens sont des enfants qui ont besoin
d'écouté je me dis même quand il dit ça
te plaît beaucoup d'éducation voilà nous
mêmes que l'année dernière mais voilà le
savent il ya peut-être un remède qui est
peut-être un moyen terme ou à long terme
et c'est l'éducation bien sort on se
trouve la fin c'est faux il faut que
d'abord un qui puisse s'exprimer et
qu'on aille jusqu'au bout en disant bon
bah tu dis que c'est bien pourquoi
est-ce que d'après toi c'est bien
pourquoi c'est bien d'avoir tué je n'ai
pas compris que les diversités par
exemple là dessus ça il faut aller
jusqu'au bout et ensuite par rapport à
l'éducation
c'est regrettable mais c'est très
symptomatique
ces enfants qui souvent sont musulmans
se sont sentis agressés ou en tout cas
leurs familles ont pu se sentir agressés
déjà qu'on représente le prophète alors
que dans l'islam
c'est ça ne se fait pas et puis que ce
soit bête et méchant mais c'est vrai que
souvent les dessins de charlie hebdo
alors tout le monde en prend pour son
grade mais souvent c'est bête et méchant
et ce n'est pas respectueux de leur
employeur et c'est pour ça que ces
enfants ils ont besoin qu'on leur
explique que effectivement la liberté
d'expression est fondamental qu
effectivement on peut ne pas cautionner
les dessins de charlie hebdo et qu'ils
ont pu le vivre comme une agression mais
que ça ne méritait pas la mort pour
autant il ya un gros travail d'écouté et
d'explication qui doit être faire la
différence entre la croyance et la
vérité on peut voir on n'est pas obligé
d'imploser sa croyance à tout le monde
c'est surtout ça
jour à la fin mais ils sont
symptomatiques de quelque chose après
c'est dans un contexte précis comme un
vous disais c'est très intéressant de
les écouter jusqu'au bout et de discuter
mais malheureusement mon asile l'école
ce n'est pas un cadre pour ça parce que
c'est un cadre d'autorité d'abord et
c'est d'aider ceux des formats où les
autorités se braque assez vite parce que
c'est pas un format l'aspect un format
ouvert 7 détenir une démocratie parce
qu'ils sont dépassés les pauvres faut
pas non plus jeunes et jeter l'anathème
sur sur les professeurs c'est que déjà
ils sont pas de tensions ils ont un oui
mais n'empêche que c'est le professeur
qui ont autant qu'ils n'ont pas besoin
programme à tenir
eux c'est très pragmatique vite j'ai pas
le temps français maths ça doit être
fait et surtout ce sont des gens qui ce
retour très vite dépassé par les
évènements qui ne savent plus réponse de
monsieur matière historique
je suis un petit peu désolé mais je ne
vois pas bien l'intérêt de laisser
s'exprimer des shoes genre c'est bien
fait qu'il crève
ils avaient ils n'ont que ce qu'ils
méritent on les a prévenus une fois et
on les a prévenus deux fois la troisième
fois en les buts
si c'est ça la liberté d'expression je
pense qu'on a restreint mais des enfants
qui dit ça il enfants dans les écoles
mais non ça ne m'intéresse pas les
laisser parler
non clairement que l'école doit être un
outil permettant à nos enfants de se
préparer à la démocratie ça c'est
extrêmement important
ça veut dire que la principale mission
de l'école à travers la connaissance la
culture c'est le développement de
l'esprit critique au bon sens du terme
l'esprit critique qu'est ce que c'est
c'est de permettre à l'individu d'avoir
sa propre pensée et c'est à l'école
qu'on apprend ça moi j'ai eu la chance
immense de rencontrer un prof moutons
j'avais j'avais 14 15 ans qui a fait de
moi le contraire d'un mouton
tout est bien tard et dire ça et donc il
a développé en moi l'esprit critique que
j'avais peut-être assez naturellement
mais ça m'a permis d'avoir ma propre
opinion ma propre pensée c'est la raison
pour laquelle je ne disais que je suis
pas un suiveur moi je veux non je j'ai
ma forme de pensée en même temps je fais
la promotion de la démocratie parce que
vous avez finalement qu'est-ce que c'est
que démocratie c'est la capacité qu'ont
nos dirigeants et nous mêmes à croire en
l'humain ça développe l'optimisme
vous savez ce que c'est que la dictature
c'est le résultat du pessimisme
à partir du moment où on ne croit plus
en l'humain on veut lui imposer la forme
qu'on ressent du bonheur et ça finit par
la dictature
tous les dictateurs sur cette planète
ont été des gens qui ont voulu imposer
leur forme de pensée et souvent enfin se
livrer de bonnes intentions et ça amène
à la dictature donc l'école doit
préparer à l'esprit critique qui vous
emmène à ger démocratie par l'optimisme
et la croyance en son prochain et là je
ne parle pas de religion je parle dans
la croyance à l'humain et puis c'est la
tradition française valeur tu dire
depuis descartes prix jack est un
parfait esprit critique à ces gamins et
sont convaincus par leurs grands frères
leurs parents car il faut leur apporter
cet esprit critique jusque il faut une
fée mais est ce que ça dit pas quelque
chose d'aussi bons jeux
vu qu'il y avait quand même des ddd des
zones où il y avait par exemple 80 %
d'enfants d'immigrés dans ces zones là
c'est comme très difficile alors ce que
vous dites sur l'esprit critique dans un
lycée de versailles ou dans un lycée
parisien
je vois tout à fait car nous avons
mustapha en février vous assurez que le
développement que moustapha faye par le
sport à la règle et d'esprit critique
il y est acteur oui mais c'est par le
sport
là vous parlez de reparler de déterminer
exactement dix ans vous aimez ce cycle
ce qui est conforme à l'esprit en forme
et bien entendu c'est pas nouveau c'est
juste la parole c'est juste que je
voulais prendre la parole pour le dire
et donc merci pour la transition un
train j'entends depuis tout à l'heure
ici mais surtout dans les ondes d'autres
chaînes et en continu il faut il faut il
faut sauf qu'à force d'entendre il faut
il faut il faut le temps passe l'espace
qui se passe rien donc c'est pas à
l'école je suis convaincu moi que c'est
pas un lieu d'ouverture de débat sur des
débats comme celui comme cela l'école a
une mission écoles l'école c'est fait
aussi pour apprendre et pour imposer ces
normes l'éducation nationale
probablement que c'est pas le bon mot
finalement l'éducation nationale on est
resté sur la notion d'éducation on
transmet un savoir on transmet des
connaissances donc on devrait en
revanche il faudrait il faut je
l'entends je le fais sur des bases
simples
c'est à dire que comme moi on
m'interroge sur nos gamins finalement
cette histoire là on en parle
aujourd'hui mais il ya d'autres
histoires dont on a parlé ans dans le
club
bien avant et qui n'était pas celle du
terrorisme et qui ssl éventuellement de
d'autres sujets le football un moment
donné ça ça a des vertus intrinsèquement
tard qu'il ya des règles et le fait une
équipe et donc nous quand on enseigne
tout simplement
donc c'est un pléonasme que de dire que
le football et éducatif
le football intrinsèquement l'est le
football intrinsèquement transmet des
valeurs la seule valeur camus la tuer
des mois je vais vous dire très
simplement je peux pas laisser dire que
les mots
ne font que répéter ce qui se dit à la
maison comme si finalement tout était
dit à la maison et que les enfants leur
projet
ça peut arriver et probablement de temps
en temps aller jusqu'à souvent mais
c'est par les gamins qui répètent
scrupuleusement ce qui se dit il ya des
tas parents qui sont qui parle comme
vous et moi et qui ont des gamins qui
disent le contraire et qui leur échappe
personne n'ose trop de cette panne n'a
évoqué les gros mots avec leurs gosses
et pourtant ils ont appris dans la rue
et ils ont répété nargue le cas des
grossièretés dans la rue qui sont pas
forcément transmises par les paroles je
tiens quand même à le dire même si ça
peut choquer certains peut-être que
c'est bien de penser dans le conseil et
les employés les passions les enfants ce
qu'est ce que ça doit être
il vous offrant des règles fois il saute
tous les enfants ils sont tellement de
ta connerie il s'auto alimente
et dans les familles parfois on est un
peu aussi dépassé dans un club de foot
pour revenir terrain de façon
terre-à-terre au club de foot le font
parce que cohn bendit dit par exemple
que le foot ça peut être un des vecteurs
qui permet à tous ces enfants qui sont
parfois un peu paumé d'avoir une
structure d'avoir une autorité d'avoir
le sens du du convoi pour les autres
déjà déjà sa pipe mot juste d'abord sa
lettre d'abord ça coûterait avec
efficacité
non mais attendez on parle de foot parce
que je ferai tous les sports et toutes
les attentions par le port de la burqa
les clivages politiques ou même
individualités donc d'abord ça coûterait
beaucoup moins cher si on mettait
beaucoup plus de moyens qu'on ne les
mettrait probablement dans l'anti
terrorisme parce que maintenant il en
faut de plus en plus de moyens vont pas
tout confondre
voilà probablement moins je vais
prévenir le foot le sport en général la
culture en général
ouais ça aide ça peut très beaucoup
moins cher deuxièmement moi je ne suis
pas non alors on parle ici mais dans le
club de foot
je fais en sorte que mes éducateurs
parle le moins possible terre que la
parole entraîne des paroles et souvent à
l'école
on libère la parole et finalement on se
rend compte qu'on a du mal à maîtriser
parce qu'on garde ça d'apparat le temps
là le feu c'est pareil à une heure et
demie pour jouer et un moment donné on
revient des fondamentaux les
fondamentaux c'est le foot
quand tu es à l'école de foot tu es là
pour apprendre donc quand il ya des
débats qui s'ouvrent et qui sont hors du
champ de la laïcité pour le coup ou dans
le champ politique
le football ne permet pas ça sauf que si
on voulait faire une image du football
sport collectif et non pas ce qu'ils
veulent et je termine et je t'aimerai je
termine là dessus le football intègre
tout le monde
la république doit intégrer tout le
monde le foot
regarde les compétences parce qu'on fait
par jouer n'importe qui n'importe
qu'elle passe la république doit aussi
regarder les gens par leur compétence la
dernière fois à des postes qu'on a
applaudi en arabe c'était la même
c'était le policier qui fait l'essence
voilà et la fois d'avant c'était zidane
c'est lui mal donc là donc avoir des
exemples on s'exalte voir des exemples
on peut éventuellement s'exonérer de
tout le reste
je crois qu'il faut revenir à des bases
la république dont on parle doit être
exemplaire comme le foot
l'est et le terrain ne ment pas antoine
à un mot rapidement juste sur cette idée
pour moi il ya intégration et puis la
démocratie on peut être intégré dans une
dictature c'est une mauvaise intégration
mais c'est une intégration comme la
démocratie nécessite des formes il ya
une super association qui s'appelle
dédale qui pratiquent la pédagogie
social sur saint quentin en yvelines où
score maurice thorez attrape un est en
fait l'idée c'est d'aider les enfants à
organiser leurs activités dans la rue
sur nos enfants qui nous balade dans la
rue main est à la fin de ses activités
il ya une petite assemblée des enfants
qui décident des activités pour la
prochaine fois et donc c'est une façon
de justement d'éduquer à la démocratie
je trouve que c'est une très bonne idée
buy in il n'était pas parce que la
démocratie dans une société
instruite absolument et cultivé
b les deux cantons sur place mais je
rebondis sur ce qu'ils ne savent pas ce
qui c'est extrêmement important et
vraiment je vais dans son sens il a
totalement raison
aujourd'hui la protection de nos beauty
de nos ministères de nauru et sa part
d'états de policiers gendarmes avec la
mitraillette au poing à un coût
économique faramineux nous devrions
réfléchir deux secondes à transférer
cette dépense vers l'éducation et la
culture vient dévier des périodes
peut-être redescendre d'un cran mais
politiquement
est ce qu'il ya des gens qui profitent
de enfin les profits de 1 pas
volontairement un mais qui vont profiter
de la situation je parle je pense à
françois hollande et je pense monsieur
le premier ministre je pense que même
les deux manuel valls et deux grands
vainqueurs sont manuel valls et
cazeneuve hollande non parce que
hollande il a fait le job il est très
bien il va voir lui une sorte de charlie
blues dans peu de temps parce qu'il y
aura plus de commémoration il y aura
plus dommage il va se retrouver tout
seul à l'elysée à ne rien faire il va
vraiment faire une véritable des primes
or valls et cazeneuve ils ont montré
tous les deux vraiment un grand
professionnalisme une grande habileté
je pense que les deux vrais gagnants se
sont toutes eric manuel valls a été dit
voir tous les rangs de l'assemblée n'ont
pas sinon bah pour moi nous n'étiez pas
là faut mettre un nom ça sera
effectivement françois long ça sera
toujours un chef d'état dans des moments
où tout le monde doit se réunir ce sera
toujours un chantier gravé son nom ce
sera ça aurait été saragosse était plus
plus tôt et ça sera le prochain paris
pendant d'ailleurs joué un peu des
coudes aujourd'hui mais par contre ce
que je sais c'est qu'il incarne la
france j'ai vraiment entendu hollande et
ça aurait pu être sarkozy des chefs
d'état qui à un moment donné c'est celui
qui vend des moments comme ça
le 10 mai le dise oh no de centaines et
des centaines d'années que la france
s'est construite sur des valeurs et ils
ont transcendé ils les ont exprimés dans
ces moments là mais je pense que si
sarko a été là je pense les mêmes choses
les mêmes mots avec sa façon de dire et
donc c'est le président république qui
s'en sort j'ai envie de dire de la
france
c'est la france sur moi j'agis d'accord
dans une fois n'est pas coutume mais oui
évidemment que la représentation que
françois hollande a fait de l'état mais
ça peut être dur interne hauteur non non
ce n'est pas une société où on va
discuter la bande mais revenait non mais
vous savez celui qui attaque heures est
ce que c'est un vainqueur à moyen terme
là non pas que bien sûr sur le moment
mais puisque ça va durer a pour moi ce
qui est un état de grâce
c'est moins l'affairé où ça demeurera
hollande redescendre à y reviendra à la
hauteur de la france évidemment mais lui
je crois pas non ce qui a gagné le plus
probablement à l'échelle de l'opinion
internationale
c'est la france c'est charlie et
j'espère j'espère que je disais tout à
l'heure qu'il ya un message qui a été
lancée et que les politiques volent ou
intellectuellement et encourager en
volonté politique et en idées et essayer
de remonter un peu d'un cran mais je
pense que j'espère qu'on pourra peut
plus faire de la politique comme avant
et qu'on sera plus courageuse une c
pendant qu'ils seront tous petits mist
car c'est le chemin vers la démocratie
c'est vrai le pessimisme net à la
dictature
c'est vraiment moi de nature plutôt
optimiste eu plus dubitatif parce que
c'est vrai société de l'immédiateté
alors on parlait d' événement historique
ou pas tout à l'heure j'aimerais que ce
soit 1 mais je n'en suis pas sûr j'ai
peur qu'on revienne chacun notre train
train quotidien disent sûrs de la raison
est que les politiques de la même façon
d'ici peu de temps reviendront à leur
suis écoute un sérieux de jouer
non moi je pense qu'il ya pas de gagnant
contient des morts tout simplement une
faute personnes à gagner personne a
guéri dans 9 mai mais on ne tirait des
bénéfices politiques d'une situation
quelle qu'elle soit même si elle est
dramatique
il ya des révolutions qui ont été
obligés de tuer pour arriver à la
liberté quand il était sous le joug de
dictateurs dont parfois il ya des gens
qui ont choisi de mourir soi-même pour
laisser vivre d'autres donc c'est vrai
que c'est une belle formule il ya
personne a gagné quand il ya un mort
mais à un moment donné ils ont paniqué
ils n'ont pas choisi de mourir et
franchement maintenant qu'ils sont
partis il faut qu'il soit parti pour
quelque chose de très très fort et c'est
la charte qui a refusé sur la plier qui
a été dit voilà je pense des jeux me
faire des comptes chez lui à genève
voilà continue à dire et et j'assume ce
truc est c'est fait remarquable donc
elle compte des charges est chargé du
travail alors révolution pacifique non
violente et eh bien on en reparlera si
je voulais dans le prochain 20 juin
prochain pape
merci à tous les sept ont été nombreux
fans étaient nombreux
donc ça passe et huit bombes avant
c'était comme ça merci à tous et à très
vite pour un prochain
bref